[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامجا اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبايقاع سريع
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين
عاد نتنياهو فعادت الضربات داخل ايران
طهران مخترقه واشنطن وتل ابيب تعرفان
الكثير
الحكومه الوليده مستقبلها على المحك مشاكل
نتنياهو الداخليه كثيره انقسام في الجيش
وعراك مع القضاء
وفي ملفات الساعه ستون ترامب يعود الوثائق
التي تضعفه تقويه والامريكيون يسالون
بايدن سؤالا طرحه قبل اشهر
منتصف مايو تركيا امام اهم استحقا في
تاريخها الحديث ولايه ثانيه ام ثالثه
لاردوغان
[موسيقى]
المسيرات الايرانيه قد تحول احدى المدن
الاسرائيليه في اي حرب قادمه الى كييف
ثانيه تحذير اطلقه مركز ابحاث الامن
القوميه الاسرائيلي لا يحتاج رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل نتنياهو التوصيه فبعودته عاده
الضربات في العمق الايراني هجمات على
منشاه عسكريه في اصفهان تجرى فيها تجميع
صواريخ متوسطه المدى مثل شهاب القادره على
ضرب اسرائيل تل ابيب لم تعترف حتى الان
بانها المنفذ لكن مسؤولين امريكيين اكدوا
مسؤوليتها الامر اكده ايضا رونال برمان في
نيويورك تايمز وهو الصحفي المعروف بصيلاته
الوثيقه في اجهزه الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
الموساد نفد العمليه والمسيرات انطلقت من
داخل ايران هذا الاحتمال الاقرب يدعمه ان
مسيره من طراز اسرائيليه نفذت الهجوم بحسب
ما اعلنته ال الامنيه الايرانيه ولهذه
الطائره تحديدا في الفتره الاخيره سجل في
استهداف اذرع ايران الولايات المتحده نفت
مشاركتها في الضربه لكن هناك امر لافت
حدثت الضربه في نفس اليوم الذي تواجد فيه
مدير الاستخبارات المركزيه الاميركيه في
اسرائيل الرجل الذي يصفه مسؤولون امريكيون
سابقون بانه الرجل المناسب للتعامل مع
الايرانيين وملفهم النووي قبل برنس كان
مستشار الامن القومي
في تل ابيب وهاتان الزيارتان مهدتان اخرى
ثالثه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي زار
المنطقه واسرائيل في اول جوله منذ عوده
نتنياهو لمنصبه النضال المشترك ضد ايران
كان عنوان زياره بلينك لاسرائيل اكد
مواجهه برنامج طهران النووي واستمرار
الدعم الامني لتل ابيب والواضح وبتعبير تل
ابيب الزياره بعثت برسائل لخصوم اسرائيل
تاتي زيارتك في وقت حرج وهي تبعث رساله
واضحه لخصومنا وكذلك لشركائنا في المنطقه
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل المتحده في
ضروره مواجهه ايران وكل من يهدد السلام
والاستقرار
اخر لحادثه اصفهان الهجوم قد يكون مقدمه
لحرب للوكاله مع روسيا قد تمتد الى مساحات
اخرى خارج اوروبا بعد استهداف المنشاه
تغريده اثارت الجدل وزادت الغموض حول
المنفذ وهي لمستشار الرئيس الاوكرانيين من
خليو بودالياك الضربه في اصفهان مرتبطه
بالحرب في اوكرانيا وطبعا مسيره شاهد 136
الايرانيه اصبحت جزءا رئيسيا من ادوات
روسيا في حربها ضد اوكرانيا وهنا اسرائيل
قد تكون لاعبا جديدا في الحرب الاوكرانيه
والتاكيد جاء بشكل مباشر من نتنياهو ندرس
امكانيه ارسال مساعدات عسكريه
نتنياهو لفتى لامر مهم خلال المقابله التي
اجراها مع السيان ان نتصرف بطرق لن افصلها
ضد مصانع الاسلحه الايرانيه التي تستخدم
الولايات المتحده اخذت جزءا كبيرا من
الذخائر المخصصه لاسرائيل وسلمتها الى
اوكرانيا وبصراحه فان اسرائيل ايضا تتصرف
بطرق لن افصلها هنا ضد مصانع الاسلحه
الايرانيه التي تستخدم ضد اوكرانيا
سواء كان هجوما مشتركا او احاديا الثابت
انه لا يمكن لايران ان تمتلك سلاحا نوويا
تل ابيب وواشط تؤكدان المؤكد والمؤكد ايضا
ان مسيرات ايران في اوكرانيا باتت تستنفذ
الصبر الاستراتيجيه الامريكي تجاهها وتحفز
عقيده الاخطبوط الاسرائيلي الاستراتيجيه
لرئيس الوزراء السابق بنت باستهداف ايران
وليس فقط اذرعها من افضل منا تنياهو
لتطبيقها في الحقيقه هو اكثر من يعرف عن
ايران وطموحاتها النوويه منذ 2019
50 الف صفحه
اضافه الى خمسه وخمسين الف ملف اخر حملت
على 183 قرصا مضغوطا
اولا ايران تزعم انها لا تمتلك برنامجا
نوويا عسكريا
لكن 150 الف ملف سري تثبت العكس
ثانيا حتى بعد الاتفاق النووي ايران وصلت
تطوير وتوسيع برنامجها النووي لاستعمالها
في المستقبل السؤال لماذا يحاول نظام
ارهابي اخفاء الملفات النوويه لاستعمالها
في المستقبل ثالثا
الولايات المتحده تعرف الكثير ايضا
فالوصول الى ارش في ايران النووي كما
شاهدنا كان جهدا امريكيا اسرائيليا مشتركا
وهذا ما اكده
السابق في كتابه وعلى ضوء المكشوف
والمعروف وقع هجوم المسيرات على اربعه
مواقع لكن يجدر الوقوف عند هجوم اصفهان
ليس للجدل الدائر حول نجاح العمليه وصعوبه
مطابقه الصور التي نشرتها السلطات
الايرانيه والتي بالكاد تظهر اي تاثير
وبينما رصدته كاميرات الايرانيين لحظه
وقوع الهجوم الوقفه هنا تتعلق
بطبيعه الموقع مركز ابحاث الفضاء وهنا
ووفقا للاستخبارات الاسرائيليه مصنع
لتصنيع صواريخ باليستيه مقلقه لماذا
الى جانب السريه التي تحيط بمواقع عسكريه
عده وسنفصلها بعد قليل تقدر التل ابيب
امكانيه تصنيع ايران لصواريخ قادره على
حمل رؤوس النوويه خلال عامين منطلقها من
مركز الفضاء او المصنع في حرمه وذلك لان
المشتبه بهما هما زولجانا وقائم 100
صاروخاني لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه
الايرانيه يجرى تطوير نسخ عسكريه منها
وصحيفتها ارت نقلت المزيد من التفاصيل عن
المسؤولين العمليه ستمكن الصاروخين من حمل
راس نووي بوزن نصف طن والوصول الى مسافه
تتجاوز 4000 كيلو متر اذا اسرائيل تعرف
الكثير في ديسمبر 2018 كشفت وثائقه
للمعارضه الايرانيه اخفاء حكومه طهران
مواقع عسكريه سريه الى جانب المواقع
الخمسه
اشكال اباد واشيان لفيسان وفوردو الوثائق
التي قدمت لصحيفه البريطانيه اظهرت وجود
اربع منشات شاركت في جوانب مختلفه من
المشروع النووي وشملت مواقع في باجهش كادي
في مجمع برشين العسكري وموقع نوري الصناعي
الواقع في مجمع خزير العسكري وهفتير في
قاعده تحمل نفس الاسم وسنغريان بالقرب من
مجمع بارشي واحين جاء كشف اصفهان من قبل
نتنياهو لم يكن ذلك مفاجئا فاصبهان مركز
صناعه الصواريخ الايرانيه لكن هي ايضا تضم
مصنعنا لتخصيب اليورانيوم واخر لانتاج
اجهزه الطرد المتطوره ومصنعا للمسيرات
والذي ينتج بالمناسبه شاهد 136 المستخدمه
في اوكرانيا لكن لماذا كان الهدف مصنع
الصواريخ حصرا الاجابه واضحه لتل ابيب
ولها اولوياتها الصواريخ كما ذكرنا هي
معادله النوويه الايرانيه اكبر الاخطار
بالنسبه لاسرائيل وبحسب تصنيف استراتيجي
تصنيفا استراتيجي لمعهد الدراسات الامن
القوميه الاسرائيلي تنقل صحيفه معاريف عن
تمير هيمان ورئيسه هو ايضا رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه السابق
تنقل امرا اخر مثيرا للاهتمام يقول هيمان
انه اوصى نتنياهو بالخطوه الدراماتيكيه
الاخيره في الصندوق الغربي تدمير الاتفاق
النووي بالكامل بالانسحاب الاوروبي منه
عواقب ذلك طبعا معروفه اعاده فرض اليه
سناب باك عقوبات مجلس الامن لكن من تقلق
هذه الخطوه امريكا لانها تخشى الرد
الايراني والكلام هنا لا يزال
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سنتابع هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
للمتحدث باسم البنتاجون
مره اخرى
هذا منطاد
تجسس
ويحلقوا على ارتفاع 60 الف قدم ومن الواضح
باننا اجرينا تقييما دقيقا حول ما يفعله
هذا المنطاد وكما اسلفت الذكر
القاده العسكريون قيموا بانه ما من تهديد
عسكري او فعلي للناس على الارض وفي هذا
الخصوص فاننا مستمرون في المراقبه بالنسبه
فيما يتعلق في الخطوات القادمه فاننا ننظر
في كافه الخطوات لن استعجل في طرح هذه
الخطوات المقبله شكرا قلتم ان هذا يشكل
انتهاكا للفضاء الجوي لماذا لا تسقطوه اذا
من الواضح من خلال تقييمنا للخيارات
المتاحه والنظر لحجم هذا المونتاج
واحتمالاتي التساقط بقايا بقايا في حاله
في حاله اسقاطه والاضرار الذي قد يخلفها
على المباني والمدنيين هذا قد يكون احد
العوامل التي اخذناها في عين الاعتبار
واذا ما كان يشكل خطرا محتملا على حركه
الطائرات والان كما قلت بانه لا يشكل خطرا
على الناس في الارض لانه يعبر قاره
الولايات المتحده
لدينا مجموعه من الخيارات
لناخذها ونحن الان مستمرون في دراسه كافه
الخيارات ذكرتم بانكم رايتم نشاطا ما
لماذا شطورنا هذه النشاطات ومنذ يوم الامس
او يومين قد تكون هذه اشاره يجب ان ناخذها
في عين الاعتبارات او او جاءت على خلفيه
لزياره الوزير اوستن الى الفلبين بالنسبه
لاي اشاره في هذا الخصوص قد تكون الامور
هذه المره مختلفه
بسبب انتهاك هذا المنطاد لاجوائي الولايات
المتحده
يوم الامس احد كبار المسؤولين في وزاره
الدفاع قال بان قدرات
هذا المنطاد قد تكون اقل من
الاقمار الصناعيه الاخرى التي تطلقها عاده
احيلك الى
التقرير الصحفي
كما قلت اننا نراقب هذا الامر وقد انتهك
الفضاء الجوي الامريكي وقد انتهك القوانين
الدوليه
وهذا ما اقدمت عليه الحكومه الصينيه
لكنني احيلك الى النشر الصحفيه
اعتمادا على ما قد يفعله هذا المنطاد
منطقه التجسس اذا لم يكن هناك اي جمع
لمعلومات يتم الحصول عليها من اقمار
صناعيه
هل هذا هل هذا بيان ام سؤال لا توجد لدي
اي معلومات لاضيفها هنا
هل هناك اي طريقه يمكن من خلالها ان يقيس
حجمه وتاثيري هذا المنطاد بالمقارنه مع اي
معدات اخرى اطلقتها الصين في السابقه كما
قلت سوف نستمر في المراقبه والان قدرنا
بانه سوف
سوف يبقى هذا المنطاد في اجواء الولايات
المتحده لبضعه ايام وسوف نراجع كافه
خياراتنا وسوف نبقيكم على الطلاء بهذا
الشان
اذا مشاهدينا كان هذا مؤتمر الصحفي
للمتحدث باسم البنت
قال فيه حول المنطاد الذي يحلق فوق شمال
غربي الولايات المتحده حيث توجد قواعد
جويه حساسه قال رايدر ان هذا المنطاد هو
منطاد تجسس صيني يحلق على ارتفاع 60 الف
قدم لا توجد اي تهديد على المواطنين حاليا
الامريكيين لكن ستستمر الولايات المتحده
والبينتاغون في المراقبه وانه من خلال
تقييم حجم المنطاد في حال اسقاطه سيكون
هناك خطر سيتشكل على المواطنين اذا سنستمر
في متابعه المزيد من التفاصيل والتطورات
حول موضوع المنطاد الصيني الذي ارصد في
الاجواء الامريكيه والذي ايضا قال
باتريكريدر انه خرق وانتهاك للفضاء الجوي
والقوانين الدوليه اذا نعود لاستكمال ملف
ايران الان
ونعود الى الخطوه الدراماتيكيه التي
اتحدثنا عنها والتي اوصت بها تل ابيب اوصى
بها المعهد للامن القومي لنتنياهو اذا
الاجابه هنا عن هذه الخطوه ليست في تل
ابيب بل في واشنطن ولدا روبرت مالي
المبعوث الامريكي لايران وبتاكيده ان
بلاده وحلفائها الاوروبيين متحدون اليوم
في مواجهه ايران اكثر مما كانت عليه الحال
في السابق ايران التي باتت قريبه جدا جدا
من الحصول على كميه كافيه من اليورانيوم
المخصب بانتاج سلاح نووي ابي حسب مالي اما
عن كم هي قريبه من الحصول على القنبله
فهذا سؤال اخر اجابه مالي بالاتي ان ذلك
يستوجب وقتا اطول واذا اقتربت هذه الخطوه
فالمعطيات لدى الولايات المتحده ستتغير
ذكر مالي بقول الرئيس بايدن اذا فشل
الاتفاق فكل الخيارات الاخرى على الطاوله
العسكري اهمها بالطبع لكنه رفض تاكيد
تصريح بايدن الاكثر اهميه الذي يتعلق بموت
الاتفاق النووي
بواس اوكي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا سامويل
المتحدث الاقليميه باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه اهلا بك اذا اسرائيل
استراتيجياتها واضحه سواء بسياسه الالف
جرح او الاخطبوط التي وضعها بنت والان
نتنياهو يعرف الكثير عن ايران ولديه خطه
على ما يبدو لكن اذا كانت العزم كان العزم
على الضربات من قبل اسرائيل هو الخطه ما
هي الخطه في الولايات المتحده
الاداره شكرا استضافه وهذه الاداره رئيس
بايدن هو يرى ان مازال هناك امكانيه
للدبلوماسيه ونحن دائما نفضل المسار
الدبلوماسي وكان لدينا النص من الاتحاد
الاوروبي في شهر اكتوبر او شهر سبتمبر
وكان كل الاطراف في مجموعه خمسه زائد واحد
في المفاوضات حول برنامج النووي الايراني
كان يتفقوا على هذا النص ولكن في نهايه
المطاف جانب الايراني رفضوا لماذا ليس من
الممكن ان نقول اذا لذلك الرئيس باين انه
هو قال اننا نحن مستعدون للكل من
السيناريوهات مع العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي او بدونها
لكن ان الاتفاق قد
مات لم يؤكد هذه النقطه تحديدا اين يعني
الان المفاوضات اين تجدون هذه النقطه هل
هي نقطه
قربت على الانتهاء هل فرص الولايات
المتحده انتهت لايران من الممكن ان نقول
الرساله لدينا من كل الاشارات من الجانب
الايراني ان
المفوذات مات الان لان ليس هناك اي رد
ايجابي او اي رد بنا من الجانب الايراني
نحن وكل الاطراف الاخرى في المجموعه
الخامسه زائد واحد نحن كنا مستعدون
للدبلوماسيه ولكن الان تركيزنا ليس على
المفاوضات او البرنامج
الى تقارب غير مسبوق مع الحلفاء
الاوروبيين في
الاتفاق النووي وهناك ايضا ضغوط اسرائيليه
بتوصيه او التوصيه لنقل بالانسحاب
الاوروبي من هذا الاتفاق وبالتالي فرض
اليه سنابات مجددا على ايران هل هذا
الخيار مطروح في الولايات المتحده الان
اذا لدينا تواصل عن كذب وقريب مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع الدوله الاوروبيه الثلاثه في
المجموعه خمسه زي الوعد وما الجانب
الاسرائيلي لان نحن نعرف انه ندركنا ايران
تمثل تحدي كبير وعميق ليس فقط اسرائيل
ولكن كل الدول في هذه المنطقه اذا لدينا
هذا التواصل
وهذه الاداره ترى ان التنسيق المتحده ودول
اخرى في مجموع خمسه زائد واحد اهم شيء
ولازم نقارن ذلك ما فعل الاداره سابقه
عندما قام بانسحاب من الاتفاق النووي بدون
اي تنسيق مع خلفائنا
سنستغل وجودك سيد سام معنا في الاستوديو
للتعليق على حادثه اليوم الخاصه بالمنشاط
الصيني والذي حلق فوق شمال الغربي
الولايات المتحده حيث توجد قواعد جويه
حساسه وصواريخ نوويه استراتيجيه في منشات
تحت الارض اكد تعقب المنطاد فيما ابدى
الصين اسفها لدخول المنطاد الاجواء
الامريكيه وقالت ان الامر تم دون قصد
فالمنطاد ذو الطابع مدني وظل طريقه بحسب
بكين بعد غد يوم الاحد كان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكاني يستعد لزياره
الصين لكن وبحسب مسؤول امريكي كبير
لرويترز الجلبلين الزياره ملف التجسس
والحرب التكنولوجيه بين البلدين شائك
نتوسع فيه غدا في برنامج لكن سناخذ تعقيدا
من المتحدث باسم الخارجيه عود اليك سامي
اذا كما سمعنا الان الى المؤتمر الصحفي
للمتحدث باسم قال انه منطاد تجسس وبكين
انه من طاط يعني لاغراض مدنيه كيف تنظرون
الى هذا المنطاد الان وهو تحت المراقبه
الحثيثه اذا كما ذكرت لدينا بعض الاسئله
ممكن اسئله اكثر من لدينا اجوبه الان
وهناك مستجدات كثيره اذا انا لا اريد في
هذا السياق اشاره كثير من التفاصيل ولكن
الاهم شيء وسمعنا ذلك من رئيس بايدن ووزير
واسمائنا ذلك من الجانب السني لازم تكون
هذه بلدين لدينا علاقه دبلوماسيه لازم
نكون لدينا التواصل
للتجنب اي سوء الفهم بالنسبه اي تحديات او
اي احداث مثل من راى الان اذا من جانبنا
نحن نعتبر هذا المنتج منتج تجسس نعم بدون
شك ستكون استكشافات
وتحقيقات وسنعرف اكثر في الايام المقبله
ولكن الان نحن نعرف هذا المنطب المنتج
البالون لا يمثل اي خطر للمدنيين ولا يمثل
اي خطر للطائرات المدنيه في امريكا اذا
نحن سنستمر في المراقبه
وسنعرف اكثر بعد الايام نعم اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على كل هذه الافادات شكرا
في في التطورات لهذا المنطاد وتحركاته اذا
زارت دفاعا اسرائيليه بثلاثه رؤوس في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
مهم خاصه
السبت التاسعه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
الايرانيه ليس المشكله الوحيده التي تواجه
لكن هناك رسائل تطمنينيه تخرج من
المسؤولين وهناك قياده واحده للجيش رئيس
الاركان الجديد
اذا الانقسام في الجيش ليس المشكله
الوحيده هناك ازمه داخليه اخرى غير مسبوقه
طرفاها الحكومه والمحكمه العليا وعنوانها
هو الصداع على صلاحيات القضاء خلفيه
الازمه قد تفسر احتدامها الان خلال
السنوات الماضيه باتت احزاب اليمين
الاسرائيلي تؤمنوا بان النخبه القضائيه
تقف امام تنفيذ اجندتها ترى في المحكمه
العليا عقب امام توسيع مشروعها الاستيطاني
في الضفه الغربيه لكن لنعد للشراره الاولى
عندما قرر نتنياهو ترشيح وزير القضاء
الحالي يريف اليفين للمنصب لم يكن
الاختيار عشوائيا فلدين هو من اوائل
السياسيين اليمنيين الذين طرحوا مشروع
تغيير الصلاحيات السلطه القضائيه حتى قبل
نتنياهو بحد ذاته اما الشراره الثانيه
للازمه فاندلعتها في الثامن عشر من ديسمبر
الماضي عندما استبعدت المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه رئيس حزب شاص درعي من منصبه
الوزاري كوزير للصحه والداخليه ضربه قويه
تقود اتفاقات نتنيه وربما حتى قد تؤدي الى
حل حكومته اذا ما قرر حزب شاص الانسحاب
منها القرار القضائي يدعم نظريات الحزب
التي تتهم القضاء بملاحقه زعيمها منذ
ادانته بتلقي رشه اثناء توليه وزاره
الداخليه في عام
1999 بسبب تحيزات طائفيه وتحديدا خلفيته
الشرقيه كيف جاء قرار عدم القانونيه تعيين
ارياد الرعي في منصب منصب حكوميا وقتها
وبموافقه بموافقه 10 من 11 قاضيا لكن
اللافت هو ان التسعه قضاه من بين الموافق
الموافقين العشره كانوا من اصول
الاشكنازيه والعاشر عربيا اما القاده
الوحيد الذي لم يؤيد بطلنا تعيين ذرعي
كوزير فكان من اصول شرقيه
تنفيذ خطه اصلاح القضاء سيضع حكومه
نتنياهو خاصه امام عدد من التحديات
الداخليه وخارجيه فداخليا ردت القوه
المعارضه للخطه بمظاهرات كل يوم سبت
يتراوح عدد المشاركين فيها بين 80 الفا
ومئه وخمسين الفا وهي ارقام تؤكد ان حكومه
نتنياهو لا تمتلك افضليه جماهيريه حقيقيه
بعد ان وصلت الى الحكم بفارق 30 الف صوت
فقط خلال الانتخابات الاخيره كما ان
استطلاعات الراي تشير لتاييد الراي العام
قرار المحكمه العليا
65% من المستطلعين عارضوا تعيين درعي حتى
كتله نتنياهو 43% منها قالوا انه ليس من
المناسبه تولي درع منصب وزير اتهامات اخرى
سيواجهها نتنياهو منها شخصنه الخطه بدافع
الانتقام والتحصين قبل التحقيقات معه بتهم
فساد وخيانه الامانه كان نتنياهو بنفسه من
ابرز المعارضين لاي محاولات تغييرا في
السلطه القضائيه بل اتهام الثاني فهو
استغلال السلطه فبعد 14 شهرا بعيدا عن
رئاسه الحكومه اعدن ثنياهو ترتيب اوراقه
ليعود عبره احزاب صهيونيه الصهيونيه
الدينيه وهذه الاحزاب تعادي المحكمه
العليا لان الاخيره مررت تشريعات تعتبرها
الاحزاب الدينيه مخالفه للشريعه اليهوديه
كما رفضت اعطاء الشرعيه لمئات البؤر
الاستيطانيه خارجيا سيكون نتنياهو في حرج
امام واشنطن التي لطالما تباهت بان
اسرائيل هي الاكثر ديمقراطيه في الشرق
الاوسط حقيقه حقيقه يدركها نتنياهو لذا
حرص على التاكيد على ان اي اصلاحات للقضاء
ستتم عبر توافق مع المعارضه
الى صفوف الحكومه تحاول الحركه اثاره
البعد العرقي فاعتبرت ان سبب شطب عضويه
درعي في الحكومه هو العنصريه ضد اليهود
الشرقيين والحركه التي تشكلت احتجاجا على
تلك العنصريه مستغلين ان السواد الاعظم من
القضاه كانوا من اليهود الغربيين رغم ان
معظم الاسرائيليين يؤيدون القرار ضد درع
بسبب تكرار ادانته بالفساد فقد كان امضى
محكوميه بالسجن الفعلي بسبب قضيه اختلاس
ومن ابرز من ادين وسجن من اليهود الغربيين
ذوي الاصول الاوروبيه وزير الماليه السابق
عام 2009 ورئيس الوزراء هود السابق عام
من القدس العربيه
اذا من تل ابيب الى تركيا الرابع عشر من
مايو تاريخ يحمل ثقلان في تركيا انتخاباته
1950 التي انهت حكم الحزب الواحد التاريخ
قد يعيد نفسه نفس الموعد قد يكون ربما اهم
موعد سياسي في تاريخ تركيا الحديث استخدم
اردوغان صلاحيته من اجل اختيار هذا
التاريخ للانتخابات بدلا من الثامن عشر من
يونيو والهدف الترشح لولايه ثالثه
والمبررات الموسيقه كثيره واهمها تجنب
موعد الامتحانات الجامعيه وتزامن الحملات
الانتخابيه مع شهر رمضان والدور الثاني من
الانتخابات انحذف مع موسم الحج
لن يغامر باصوات المحافظين لكن الاجابه
الصحيحه تاتي من الدستور يسمح للرئيس
بتقديم الانتخابات مده 60 يوما لاغراض
تنظيميه لكنه لا يمتلك صلاحيه اسمها
الانتخابات المبكره ترشح اردوغان لولايه
ثانيه ثالثه يتطلب موافقه البرلمان على
منح صفه الانتخابات المبكره وهنا عائق
تركيبه البرلمان تمرير هذا القرار يحتاج
موافقه 360 صوتا من اصل 600 صوت وحزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم يمتلك 286 مقعدا
فقط الباقي للمعارضه التي وافقت على
الموعد الجديد لكن رفضت اعتبارها مبكرا
معركه خاسره ايضا بالنسبه لاردوغان ولذلك
رفض هو تسميتها بالمبكره وهذا يضعنا امام
السيناريو الثاني قراءه مختلفه للقوانين
لحزب اردوغان تقول المعارضه دستور 2017
اقر انتخابات مبكره اقيمت عام 2018 وبذلك
يعتبر ترشحان هذه المره يندرج تحت اطار
ولايه ثانيه لا ثالثه في كل الاحوال لن
تقف التشريعات عائقا
والسنوات العشر الماضيه اثبتت ذلك وهنا
سيناريو الثالث مشاهدينا لو رفض البرلمان
قبول ترشحه قد يقدم على حله في اي وقت
واقامه انتخابات مثيره خيارا قد يحدث فوضى
دستوريه لا شك وبينما تشير استطلاعات
الراي الى تقدم اردوغان على احزاب
المعارضه الا ان حمى الانتخابات اشتدت
بسبب عدم حسم ملايين الناخبين لقرارهم
خطاب اردوغان بالدرجه الاولى موجه نحو
الاتراك المحافظين المنتمين للتيار الديني
وهم مسانده تقليديا قوانين الجنسيه انجبت
لاعبا جديدا حصول 270 الف اجنبي على
الجنسيه جعلهم كتله انتخابيه هامه يصعب
على المعارضه استقطابها اما المعارضه
فتحاول كسب اصوات الشباب
28% منهم يعانون من البطاله ولم يستفيدوا
من اجراءات رفع الاجور اصوات النساء
بدورها باتت ناجحه بعد انسحب التركيه منذ
ايام من اتفاقيه اسطنبول لحمايه المراه
المدن الكبرى باتت مفتوحه امام المعارضه
اسطنبول ازمير وانقره باتت تحت حكم
المعارضه تعداد سكانها مجتمعه يمثل ثلث
سكان البلاد وبينما يواجه اردوغان خطابا
قوميا في الداخل لا تتردد المعارضه في كسب
ود الخارج فعمدته اسطنبول اكرم الامام
اوملو اكد ان المعارضه ستعمل على بناء
علقه متميزه في منطقه البلقان
50 الف صفحه
اضافه الى 55 الف ملف اخر حب
واماما تخبط المعارضه التركيه بدا اردوغان
حمله انتخابيه ضد منافسا غائب والاسلحه
كثيره الاقتصاد واهمها وهو الذي كان نقطه
ضعف في ولايته السابقه اجراءات بنكهه
انتخابيه زياده الحد الادنى للاجور ليبلغ
450 دولارا واضافه الى خفض سن التقاعد وهو
القرار الذي استفاد منه اكثر من مليونين
عامل ضخوا الاموال بسخاء حل مؤقت وسيؤدي
فقط لسياده التضخم بعد اشهر قليله السياسه
الخارجيه سلاح اخر ارتفعت شعبيه اردوغان
بسببها رفض رفض اردوغان انضمام السويدان
للنيتو ولعب دور الوسيط بين روسيا والدول
الغربيه وايضا تجنب الانضمام للعقوبات
المفروضه على روسيا قرار جعل تركيا ملاذا
استثمارات الروسيه لكن رغم ذلك ومع قرب
الانتخابات قدم اردوغان تنازلات غير
مسبوقه مثل الغائه سحب رخصه القياده
واعفائه طلبه الجامعات من فوائد القرود
والهدف هنا طبعا استقطاب فئه الشباب
والاستطلاعات تشير الى انهم الاقل مسانده
لاردوغان سته ملايين منهم سينتخبون للمره
الاولى ويمثلون 15 من اجمالي الناخبين
المطالب الاكثر شعبيه للمعارضه وهي اعاده
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون لاجئ سوري دفعت
اردوغان لمحاوله التقارب مع النظام السوري
والاتفاق على عوده المشروطه للاجئين
وسنفصل هذا الموضوع غدا في الساعه ستون
لكن بالحديث عن المعارضه قدمت خدمه اخرى
لاردوغان اتحاد سته احزاب رئيسيه افرز
برنامجا موحدا لكنه ما زال عاجزا عن
التوصل لتوافق بشان مرشحها اتحاد المعارضه
الطاوله السته رغم انه تحالف للعلمانيين
والمنتمين لتيارات اسلاميه وحتى رفاق
اردوغان السابقين اغلق الابواب امام
الاحزاب المحسوبه على الاكراد وهو اقصاء
لجزء من اصوات المعارضه لاردوغان لكن
التحالف قوته تكمن في البرنامج بعيدا عن
هويه مرشحها
[موسيقى]
يعني تركيا
دبوس سيستم نيسان
[موسيقى]
ما هو حجم التريليون دولار بالنسبه لنبني
بحجم الفيدراليه الامريكيه الساعه
بعد دقيقه
اهلا بكم من جديد مشحونا بخيانه هي اقرب
حلفائك بنس الذي صرح بتطلع اعضاء الحزب
لقياده جديده
ما كان ليصبح حاكما لولا دعمه كما يقول
بيبي
[تصفيق]
ده الشنط ترامب حملته الانتخابيه لسباق
2024 الرئاسي من جنوب كاليفورنيا وان كانت
ترامب خسر رهان الموجه الحمراء في
انتخابات 2022 النصفيه لكن الرهانات
السياسيه تتغير وفقا لمعطيات جديده معطيات
اليوم تقول وفقا للاستطلاع عنا
قضيتي الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها في
منتجع ترامب وتلك التي ظلت في مركز بايدن
البحري ومنزله لسنوات والتي يجرى البحث عن
المزيد منها تعد من ابرز القضايا التي
تشغلان الراي العام الامريكي بشكل متساوي
ومع قضيه اكتشاف وثائق سريه لدى مايك بنز
نائب ترامب حصل الرئيس السابق على هديه
مفاجئه تجعله اكثر عزما على العوده
الحادثتان جعلتاه يتشارك الاتهامات بسوء
التصرف بمستندات تخص الامن القومي مع
مسؤول جمهوريا واخر ديمقراطي
هو نفس السؤال
الامريكيون اليوم عليه كيف يمكن لرئيس
الولايات المتحده ان ينسى وثائق سريه بقيت
لسنوات في غرفه المجاوره لمراه بمنزله
منصات الديمقراطيين الاعلاميه حاولت
الاجابه بايظا لم ينتهك القوانين لانه لم
يعلم بوجودها ومحاموها بادروا فورا
بالابلاغ عنها رغم انهم ابقوا الاكتشاف
الثاني سرا حتى سربت قناه سي بي اس القصه
وروايه ان دفعه المستندات الاولى دفعه
المستندات الاولى وجدت داخل خزانه مقفله
وهي تعزز موقف الرئيس وحرصه بان حصنه
الوثائق التي لم يعلن عن مستوى سريتها بعد
ظلت بمكان امن لكن في نفس الوقت ذات
المنصات تصنف حادثه ترامب بالجريمه وتبرر
بان مقاومته والمحاصره محاصره قوات الاف
بي اي لمقر وجودها وانتشار صوره تؤكد
السريه المواد وعددها كبير تعرضه للمحاسبه
بموجب قانون التجسس الامريكي في حين ان
المنصات المناصره لترامب تقول ان للرئيس
السابق الحق باخذ المستندات وهو لم يخرق
القانون لانه نزع السريه عنها شفهيا قبل
تركيب منصبه المفارقه ان ترامبوا وحتى
اوباما فرضوا عقوبات جنائيه قاسيه على
المسربين للوثائق والمبلغين في عهدهم
بصوره اكبر من غيرهم والمفارقه الاكبر ان
بايدن الذي امضى عقودا كعدوا في مجلس
الشيوخ يعزز قوانين تحاكم الكشف غير
السليم عن المعلومات السريه حاكمت الاداره
التي كان جزءا منها اكبر عدد من المخالفين
بموجب قانون التجسس اكثر من جميع الادارات
الامريكيه في التاريخ مجتمعه
[موسيقى]
اذا لا تهاون مع من يعبث باسرار الدوله
بايضا وترامب اي يعلمان حساسيه هذه النقطه
وكلاهما يراهن على سقوط الاخر اعلاميا
كبرت كره الثلجي كثيرا فالحرب انتقلت من
المنصات الرقميه الى اروقه الكونغرس معركه
اخرى تضاف الى معارك انتهت احداها اخيرا
بعد 14 جوله بفوز جمهوريه برئاسه مجلس
النواب بدا رئيس لجنه المراقبه باطلاق
طلبات رسميه للحصول على معلومات حول
الوثائق وتفاصيل اكتشافها والسجل
الاتصالات بين وزاره العدل وفريق بايدن
وطلب كومر البيت الابيض والخدمه السريه
بسجلات الزائرين لمنزل بايدن في ديلاور
كما نبه رئيس الاركان من ان سوء تعامل
بايدن مع المواد السريه يثير مساله تعريض
الامن القومي للخطر كذلك فعل النائب
الجمهوري جيم جوردن اعلن عن تحقيق في مع
التركيز بشكل اولي على قرار المدعي العام
تعيين مستشارا خاص وبالمناسبه من لكن من
ترامبوا بايدن يعلم الديمقراطيون ان
موقفهم ربما اضعف في هذه المرحله ويرفضون
التعليق الى حين صدور نتيجه المستشار
الخاص لكن هناك من
اعترف هناك ايضا من الديمقراطيين من يقف
في المنتصف لنستمع
اذا كما قلنا هناك من يقف في المنتصف ايضا
كزعيم الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ تشاك تشومر
هذه الاطراف تدعم تشريع الحزبين بهدف
الحفاظ على السجلات الرئاسيه والفدراليه
بشكل عام موقفه
قد لا يكون الانسب لحزبه لكنه الاذكى في
معركه لم تتضح نتيجتها بعد وباحسن الاحوال
هو يكرر على ما اكد عليه صديقه ومنافسه
القديم
كشف عن دوافع التسريبات الثلاث لكن ترتيب
حدوثها الزمني المثالي لاستمراري مسلسلا
قضائيه يتزامن مع انطلاق الحملات
الانتخابيه لسباق 2024 الرئاسي ان كانت
مساله سوء التعامل مع الوثائق السريه امر
شائع فالسؤال هنا لماذا تتكرر هناك مؤسسه
يخصص لها يخصص لها 500 مليون دولار سنويا
للقيام بمهمه محدده وهي الحفاظ على
المستندات الحكوميه الخلل في منظومه
التصنيف والعدد يتجاوز الخمسين مليون
وثيقه سنويا يجعل تتبع جميعها امرا صعبا
ان لم يكن مستحيلا وبالنسبه لاليه التصنيف
فغالبا ما يلجا الرؤساء للخيار الاكثر حيث
تصنف جميع انواع المعلومات على انها سريه
خوفا من تسريبها للاعداء او الخصوم لكن
الافراط في التصنيف السري يعيق العمل
الصحفي ويتسبب بالتلاعب في الراي العام
والاهم ربما يسهل التهرب من المحاسبه
فالسريه لها مستويات وفقا للحساسيه
والخطوره بسبب تلك الوثائق شديده السريه
يقضي نزلاء هذا البيت والطاقم المتصل به
اصعب لحظات في حياتهم المهنيه وتحديدا هنا
في الجناح الغربي في مساحه تقدر بخمسه
الاف وخمسمائه قدم اي بحجم مستودع صغير
الحجم تقريبا هناك انشات انشات غرفه
العمليات بامر من الرئيس جون كندي عام 61
ويديرها منذ ذلك الوقت ضباط الاستخبارات
على مدار 24 ساعه في اليوم وهي نتائج قرار
اتخذ بعد فشل غزوه خليج الخنازير بسبب نقص
المعلومات في الوقت الحقيقي لحدوثها اليوم
تشكل هذه الغرفه النقطه المحوريه لتلقي
وتوزيع جميع التقارير الحكوميه منها
السريه للغايه التي توضع على الطاوله وت
وتطبخ على اثرها قرارات تؤثر على العالم
وتصنف الملفات السريه بحسب حساسيتها فمنها
لا يمكن قراءته الا من قبل فردا مسمى او
من مواقع محدده ومنها ما لا يمكن مشاركته
مع اي حكومه او فردا اجنبي باستثناء
مجموعه العيون الخمس اي تحالف الولايات
المتحده بريطانيا كندا استراليا
ونيوزيلندا والنيتو وتبقى هذه الغرفه على
اتصال بالرئيس الامريكي اينما وجد عبر
منشاه متنقله خاصه بالمعلومات الحساسه
المجزئه وهذه المنشاه مجهزه ومحصنه من اي
اختراق الكترونيا محتمل
للمره الثامنه منذ مارس 2022 رفع البنك كل
فتره الامريكي سعر الفائده التضخم
والازمات تضرب اقتصادات العالم ضبط سعر
الفائده جزء من مواجهه الازمات بجانبي
تعديل متطلبات الاحتياطيات لدى البنوك
وبجانب امر اخر
طباعه النقود تضطروا اليه البنوك المركزيه
في بعض الاحيان من اجل التحكم في المعروض
النقدي والذي يؤثر بشكل مباشر في معدلات
التضخم ومستويات الاسعار
في الولايات المتحده وفي عام 2020 مثلا ضخ
الفيدرالي الامريكي تريليونين و300 مليار
دولار من اجل تخطي تداعيات ازمه كورونا
لكن ماذا تتصور ان يكون شكل التريليون
دولار
التريليون دولار يمكن ان يغطي البنك
الفيدرالي بالمعنى الحرفي وهو المكون
الاثني عشر طابقا حيث اجمالي مساحته
203,000 متر مربع
لكنها طباعه هذه التريليونات امر مكلف
مليار دولار هي تكلفه طباعه الاموال في
امريكا العام الماضي تخيلوا الرقم طباعه
الاموال عاده لاي دوله لديها عمله خاصه
امر يؤدي للتضخم والهويه الاقتصاديه لكن
امريكا لا تتاثر مثل كل الدول وذلك بسبب
مكانه الدولار في النظام النقدي العالمي
فالعمله الخضراء هي الجزء الاكبر من
احتياطيات جميع البنوك المركزيه حول
العالم
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى نهايه الساعه وتتابعنا
في حلقه الساعه 60 غدا دقت ساعه الحظر على
المنتجات البتروليه الروسيه من المستفيد
ومن المتاثر لعبه الكراسي الموسيقيه حرب
تكنولوجيه مستعره بين واشنطن وبيكين اخرها
حادثه المنطاد من المنتصر استراتيجيه
الصين ام تكتيك وامريكا
في نهايه الساعه ابرز احداث الساعه بصور
من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]